the studio started calling me and gave
me the news and it was all official
yeah it was crazy what kid doesn't dream
about becoming spider-man
well for tom holland that dream became a
reality
greetings fellow spidey fans it's hard
to imagine anyone else besides tom
holland playing the mcu spider-man
and it's even harder to see any other
actor or actress playing his family
friends and foes today we'll be taking a
look at behind the scenes of how some of
your favorite spider-man
stars got their roles you know i wanted
to get into movies and this is finally
it and it's crazy that it's
spider-man holland's audition process
lasted a lengthy
seven months including screen tests with
both robert downey jr and
chris evans during his test with downey
holland's agent warned him that marvel
preferred that their actors stick to the
script
the iron man star ended up going off
script leading the two to riff off each
other
holland left the audition hopeful and
even called his mom to tell her he
thought he may have landed the park
six weeks went by which caused holland
to lose hope
but sure enough he was flown back out to
atlanta to do a screen test with evans
after weeks of not hearing back he
assumed that he lost the part
until one fateful day when he saw an
instagram post from marvel
i type in marvel i've still got the
article saved on my computer
i did it and it says we would like to
introduce our new spider-man tom holland
i ran downstairs i was telling my family
i got it i got it i got the park got the
park
zendaya initially didn't know she was
auditioning for a brand new spider-man
pick with the casting call
vaguely calling for a girl in movie i
didn't even know what kind of character
i was going to play till like i got
there and got to
sign a disc non-disclosure her auditions
went flawlessly
holland recalled that the producers knew
right away that they found their mj
she came in and they cast her before she
even left the room
upon dropping out of college in hawaii
batalon found himself a talent agent who
advised him to join the new year
conservatory for dramatic arts
he initially didn't even have much of an
interest in acting
i want to be a musician at first i when
i was going to college
in hawaii i was studying music theory
but then i dropped out
and then acting just kind of happened
for me film school made me really
maybe really appreciate filmmaking
during his final year
he did his very first audition sending
in a self-taped submission
for a supporting role in a marvel movie
never thinking
it'd go anywhere as faye would tell
batalon received a callback
and was flown out to burbank to perform
a screen test with tom
holland battalion described the audition
as nerve-wracking
stating that tom had a really good time
but i was shaking in my shoes
but it was really fun gyllenhaal has
gone on record to say
that it's the character driven films
like donnie darko and nightcrawler that
have attracted him the most
when gyllenhaal received a call from far
from home director john watts
about potentially playing the role of
mysterio he stated that he had to do his
research
first to see if it'd be the kind of role
that he's keen on playing
that has always been my desire to find
something in that space that seems to
match my skill
and also what i love and my own honesty
and it just so happened that it does
with that part
rivalry initially auditioned to play the
web head himself
since the casting call was open to any
ethnicity he claimed
that while it was fun he felt like he
botched his audition
he would later return to audition for
the role of ned getting called back
multiple times before the producers
realized they had another role in mind
for him
flash thompson revolori wasn't told the
name of the character
and was told to recite the lines of biff
tannin from back to the future
as a comic book fan he ultimately put
two and two together
and realized that he was actually
auditioning for flash
tomei initially wasn't aware of the ant
made character
in the comics and went through the
entire negotiation talks
not knowing her character was
traditionally depicted as a senior
citizen
tomei claims she was horrified upon
learning more about the character
she and the producers initially
considered giving her character her
traditional silver locks before
ultimately going a completely new route
with the character that tomei would be
more comfortable playing
from the time the creative team behind
homecoming decided that vulture would be
the villain
they knew right away which actor they
wanted to portray the classic spider-man
foe
michael keaton surprisingly kitten
almost wasn't cast in the role as talks
initially fell through
due to scheduling conflicts in the end
keaton did land the part
and now it's hard to picture anybody
else in the role of the winged villain
he's audition process didn't last nearly
as long as some of his other co-stars
when it came to being cast as peter's
romantic rival brad davis
sent in in audition tape and there were
fake lines that i'd use
so i didn't know what i was doing and
then i just got a call that said
do you want a role in spider-man within
the span of a week
he was flown out to london to join his
co-stars on set of the blockbuster
sequel
harrier revealed that she was simply
just sent the casting call for her
character liz
you know you get this email like
spiderman like oh yeah that's
never gonna happen but then i had
another one
and another one and then i had a screen
test
during this process she was able to
learn more about the character of liz
and how this incarnation would be
different from the comics
upon hearing about zendaya's casting
harrier thought she had lost the role
but a call with her agent reassured her
that she was still in the running for
liz
rice was just coming off her breakout
role in the nice guys
upon being cast in the role she revealed
that she was actually participating in
the audition process for betty brandt
while doing press for the crime comedy
toda like revelry initially auditioned
for the role of ned
but after losing the part the film's
producers told her that they still
wanted her in the film
peter's classmate seymour toda noted
that the character wasn't
initially written for a specific
orientation but worked with watts to
inject more of her personality
into the character smooth actually made
his marvel debut in an audi commercial
alongside holland and was able to make
connections on set
thanks to his work on the commercial he
soon got a call to being far from home
which he happily accepted you okay
i'm fine linda borg's charisma and great
reputation helped him land the part of
jason
he recalls having dinner with watts with
the director telling him
hey when i asked around everyone said
that you were really good to work with
the reason we stopped pursuing other
actors was because people said
they didn't like them simmons memorably
played j
jonah jameson in sam raimi's original
trilogy
but despite it being the same character
kevin feige has made it clear that it is
not the same incarnation
feige and watts even made plans that if
simmons turned the rule down that they'd
have to completely reinvent the
character it's great to have the
opportunity as these things evolve
to to be one of the holdovers from from
the previous version
barrick is one of the first openly trans
actors in the mcu
he had actually auditioned last minute
but was quickly cast and was flown out
to film in london
he appreciated that his character's
gender identity didn't define his
personality
and that he was simply just along for
the ride
audiences around the world have come to
love the cast of marvel studios
spider-man franchise
and it's obvious why the cast has come
from all different kinds of backgrounds
giving the films a diverse point of view
it'd be hard for us to picture a
spider-man movie going any other way
who's your favorite actor or actress
from the spider-man films